hey this is fascinating news and many of
you I know will take great pleasure in
this Alex Jones's Infowars has filed for
bankruptcy now I'm going to tell you
right up front
this stinks to high heaven and you're
gonna start to figure out why in a
moment but here's the report from
Reuters far right wing website Infowars
yesterday Sunday filed for voluntary
chapter 11 bankruptcy protection
in the face of multiple defamation
lawsuits chapter 11 bankruptcy puts a
hold on all civil litigation matters and
allows companies to prepare turnaround
plans while remaining operational Alex
Jones founder of Infowars was found
liable for damages in a trio of lawsuits
last year after he falsely claimed the
2012 Sandy Hook school massacre was a
hoax Jones claimed the shooting in which
20 children and six School Employees
were shot dead was fabricated by gun
control Advocates Sandy Hook families in
late March rejected his offer to settle
and reopen the case Jones offered to pay
120 Grand to each of the 13 plaintiffs
each of the plaintiffs turned it down
Info Wars listed its estimated Assets in
the range of zero to fifty thousand
dollars and estimated liabilities in the
range of one to ten million dollars
Infowars reportedly made
165 million dollars over three years
according to records so right away many
of you emailed me with the exact thought
that I had is this a fraudulent
bankruptcy has money just been moved and
moved and moved and difficult to track
ways and now Alex Jones is saying we
don't have any money and we're bankrupt
and we're not going to be able to pay
anybody is that really what's going on I
don't know it does stink and if you have
revenues of 165 million over three years
fifty thousand dollars you know it
that's a rounding error it is difficult
to believe that a company with a you
know 50 million 55 million dollars a
year in Revenue doesn't even have 50
grand in cash on hand now he claims that
liabilities are between 1 and 10 million
dollars so is it possible that all of
the legal fees have drained the Infowars
reserves I don't know
but it smells very very funky if there's
any real false flag operation it's more
likely that it's Alex Jones lying about
not having any money than it is the
things he said about Sandy Hook so
hopefully the court will assign a
forensic accountant to look at if and
when money was moved because he knew the
court was going to take the money and
give it to people in settlements
um it is not if you have competent
counsel lawyers and accountants it's
it's shockingly easy to make money
disappear into you know a black hole of
overseas accounts and it would really
take a lot of work to track it down so I
don't know what's going on it would be
in some sense delightful to see such a
corrosive media influence no longer be
financially viable and when I say that
it's like you know I don't wish for
people to get coveted and die I don't
wish for people to be unable to feed
themselves by not having any money but
the world would be better off without
Infowars and without Alex Jones
supplements being sold and that's a
large share of the money that they make
so the truth of this bankruptcy I I
genuinely have no idea
I think you're right to be skeptical as
many of you who emailed me are
do you know the fastest growing crime in
the United States for years the rate of
this crime has been surging the crime is
identity theft and it happens way more
often than you might think it's happened
to me I've talked about this on the show
before and it can be really bad
sometimes you get a text that your email
password has been changed your bank
calls about unusual activity your PayPal
account is getting drained and it can
happen very very quickly to keep my
accounts protected I use Aura our
sponsor Aura is Identity Theft
Protection fraud monitoring and password
management all wrapped into one Aura
monitors the dark web for your
information they monitor your credit
card they monitor your bank accounts my
subscription to Aura gives me peace of
mind protects my devices it protects all
of my different accounts and I can
monitor everything in one place on the
app if I get attacked or actually takes
action to prevent and resolve the issues
in real time and Aura is letting my
audience try it completely free for 14
days go to aura.com Pacman the link is
down below